♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO WHEN THE PROTESTS
FIRST ERUPTED, THE MAYOR OF
OLYMPIA, WASHINGTON, WAS WORRIED
THERE WITH SUPPORTIVE AND
THROWING HER OWN CITY UNDER THE
BUS.
CHERYL SELBY SAID HER
PREDOMINATELY WHITE TOWN WAS NOT
AS WELCOMING AND NURTURING TO
MINORITIES AND THE LIGHT
SWITCHED ON BY MR. FLOYD’S
MURDER NOW SHINES GLARINGLY ON
OLYMPIA.
WHEN THAT LIGHT FOCUSES ON YOUR
ACTUAL HOUSE, THE TUNE CHANGES.
AFTER WOKE VANDALS DAMAGED HER
HOME, ARE PREDOMINANTLY WHITE
TOWN WAS SUDDENLY VICTIMIZED BY
WHAT SHE CALLED DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
THE RIOTERS HAD COVERED HER
FRONT DOOR AND PORCH WITH
SPRAY-PAINTED MESSAGES.
IT’S UNFAIR, SHE WHINED.
IT’S LIKE THE STORY WE CITED
AFTER THIS ALL KICKED OFF.
A FORMER ESPN WRITER DEEMED THE
VIOLENT MASSES AS ANIMALS AND
CALL THE COPS ON THEM AS THEY
NEARED HIS HOUSE.
THAT HAPPENED JUST AFTER HE
URGED THEM TO BURN IT ALL DOWN
WHILE RETREATING A BUILDING IN
FLAMES.
LOW-INCOME HOUSING IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
SOMEPLACE FAR AWAY.
BUT THEN THE FIRE GOT CLOSER AND
PALMER FELT THE HEAT OF HIS OWN
WOKENESS.
I’M NOT GOING TO SAY IT WILL DO
SO BECAUSE OF YOUR LISTENING,
YOU ALREADY KNOW THAT.
I’M JUST TELLING THE TRUTH IT’S
EASY, VERY EASY TO ADMIRE AND
EVEN ENCOURAGED INSTRUCTION WHEN
YOU ARE FAR FROM IT OR WELL
PROTECTED.
WHETHER IT’S DEFENDING RIOTS OR
DEFUNDING COPS, THE LOUDEST
VOICES DON’T FRET ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
IF CELEBS DIDN’T HAVE PRIVATE
SECURITY, THEY WOULD BE BETTER
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IF YOU
DEFUND THE POLICE’S MINORITY
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BE HURT
MOST.
BUT IF YOU ARE RICH AND
POWERFUL, IT’S NOT GOING TO
TOUCH YOU UNTIL IT DOES.
JUST ASK THE MAYOR OF OLYMPIA
WHO ANALYSES TERROR IN HER FRONT
YARD.
MAYBE SHE CAN CALL THE SEATTLE
COPS.
THEY’VE GOT FREE TIME.
JESSE, NOW IT’S DOMESTIC TERROR.
HOW CONVENIENT.
>> Jesse: YEAH, WELL, I HAD
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON ON
"WATTERS WORLD" OVER THE PAST
WEEKEND.
HE IS VERY SMART, NEAR THE I.Q.
RANGE OF YOU, GREG.
TOP 20, MAY BE 10%.
HE SAID HISTORICALLY WHEN YOU
HAVE MOMENTS LIKE THIS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, USUALLY
WHAT PUTS A STOP TO THEM IS WHEN
THEY START EATING THEIR OWN, AND
RIGHT NOW YOU’RE KIND OF GETTING
CLOSE TO THE CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD SITUATION.
THEY WENT AFTER CNN
HEADQUARTERS.
THEY EVEN VANDALIZED THE AFL-CIO
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO THE HOMES
OF DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS.
IF THEY START REALLY TARGETING
THE MEDIA ELITE AND THE
POLITICAL ELITE, THAT’S WHEN
THEY ARE GOING TO SHUT THIS
DOWN.
IT’S LIKE WHEN THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT, EVERYBODY WAS ALL IN
AND THEN THEY WENT AFTER
JOE BIDEN AND NOW YOU DON’T
BELIEVE ALL WOMEN ANYMORE.
THAT GOT SHOT DOWN PRETTY
QUICKLY.
THE ONE THING I WOULD TELL THESE
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU DON’T WANT
PEOPLE ANALYZING ROWS, BUILD A
WALL.
VERY EFFECTIVE.
>> Greg: EMILY, THIS IS YOUR
NECK OF THE WOODS.
OURARE ALL OF THESE LEADERS IN
WASHINGTON COWARDLY AND CALLOW
AND NAIVE AND SILLY?
>> Emily: THEY ARE.
UNRESPONSIVE AND DELUSIONAL AND
RIDICULOUS AND WORTHLESS.
MAYOR WHEELER IN PORTLAND, HE IS
A JOKE.
REMEMBER WHEN HE LET PORTLAND’S
I.C.E. BUILDING BE OCCUPIED FOR
FIVE WEEKS, AFTER WHICH THE
HUMAN EXCREMENT AND BEETLES WERE
SO THICK THEY HAD TO HAVE A
HAZMAT TEAM COME IN.
PRETTY SURE IT WAS THE CITY’S
RESIDENTS WHOSE TAXES PAID FOR
THE CLEANUP AND THE SEATTLE
MAYOR, THE OLYMPIA MAYOR, THEY
ARE ALL THE SAME.
THEY ARE PERFORMATIVE ALLIES,
SONGBIRDS AND THEY ARE IN THE
SAME CATEGORY AS THE HOLLYWOOD
HILLS ACTIVISTS WHERE THEY SEE
THESE DELUSIONAL SOUND BITES
FROM THE SAFETY OF THEIR
SNOWFLAKE HOMES.
BUT WHEN IT REALLY HITS THE FAN,
THEN THEY WALK IT BACK AND AS
ALWAYS LIKE I KEEP SAYING, THE
BIGGEST LOSERS ARE THE RESIDENTS
AND I WAS ACTUALLY THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE MAYORS
AND THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS
ACTIVISTS IS THE FACT THAT THESE
MAYORS ARE HAVING THEIR SALARIES
PAID BY THE CITIZENS THAT THEY
KEEP LETTING DOWN.
>> Greg: YEAH.
DANA, I AM IMPRESSED THAT EMILY
HAS MENTIONED EXCREMENT TWICE IN
THE SHOW.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAN BEAT
THAT.
>> Dana: I DID NOTICE IT AND I
WAS THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU USED
TO USE A WORD.
GREG USED TO USED TO LIKE A WORD
THAT STARTED WITH THE P AND
MEANT THE SAME AS EXCREMENT AND
MAYBE YOU WOULDN’T HAVE GOTTEN
IN SO MUCH TROUBLE WITH THE
PRODUCERS HAD YOU USED THESAURUS
THESAURUS.
>> Greg: YOU JUST BEAT EMILY.
>> Dana: THEM MOB GIVETH AND
THE MOB TAKETH AWAY.
AND NOW YOU HAVE LOCAL LEADERS
THAT ARE REALIZING THAT I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS THE TOUGHEST
GOVERNMENT.
HE DIDN’T GET THEM LESS
ATTENTION.
PROBABLY DIDN’T DESERVE TO BUT
NOT TOO FAR HERE IN THE
JERSEY SHORE, THERE IS A MAYOR
AND HE HAD A SITUATION WHICH IS
TRASH TO THE BEACH ONE SATURDAY
NIGHT.
HIS RESPONSE THAT HE GAVE ON
FACEBOOK WAS SO MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN THESE OTHER MAYORS THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN WASHINGTON
STATE.
THERE ARE SOME GOOD LOCAL
ELECTED LEADERS OUT THERE.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU’RE TRYING TO FIND A
ROLE MODEL IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
DO NOT LOOK TO WASHINGTON STATE.
LOOK TO SOMEBODY LIKE PAUL
KINETRA.
>> Greg: JUAN, TAKE US HOME.
>> Juan: MY TAKE IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE REST OF THE GAME
BECAUSE TO ME IT COMES DOWN TO
ONE POINT, AMERICANS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PEACEFUL PROTEST, TO
PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY.
DEBASING SOMEBODY’S HOUSE,
THAT’S NOT PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY BUT
THE POINT IS THAT EVERYBODY HAS
A RIGHT TO GO OUT AND PROTEST,
AIR THEIR GRIEVANCES.
THEY ARE PROTESTING IN FRONT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE ON A REGULAR
BASIS THROUGHOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THAT’S THE RIGHT OF AMERICANS.
IT’S IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT FOR
ANYBODY WHO HAS A DOUBT, GO
CHECK IT OUT.
IT GOES DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL.
YOU CAN PROTEST.
I HOPE YOU’RE ALL FOR THAT.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON.
I THINK BY SAYING YOU’RE GOING
TO DEMONIZE THE PROTESTERS
BECAUSE THE MAYOR WAS SUPPORTIVE
AND THEN THEY DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
THEY WERE WRONG WITH THE PROTEST
ISN’T WRONG AND GIVE ME A MOMENT
HERE BECAUSE WHAT IS WRONG IS
WHEN YOU SEE FOR EXAMPLE THESE
WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHO
INFILTRATE A PEACEFUL PROTEST IN
OAKLAND AND KILL A SECURITY
OFFICER IN A FEDERAL BUILDING.
OR WHEN YOU HAVE THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, AGAIN, INTERRUPT A
PROTEST IN ALBUQUERQUE AND KILL
A PROTESTER.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON.
THAT’S THE PATTERN.
WE SHOULD CALL ATTENTION TO IT
BUT THE MEDIA DOESN’T CALL AS